ALL RIGHT, IT'S TIME FOR OUR
NEXT GAME, FIC PICS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
FAN FICTION, IS THERE ANYTHING
IT CANNOT DO EXCEPT MAKE ME THE
NEXT DOCTOR?
DAMNED YOU, CAPALDI!
ALL RIGHT, I AM GOING TO READ
YOU GUYS SOME FAN FICTION AND
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU
TO TELL ME WHO STARS IN SAID
FAN FICTION.
ALL RIGHT.
SO THIS FIRST ONE, IS IT CLINT
EASTWOOD OR MITT ROMNEY?
HE WORE A MOHAWK OF A WIG, A
$20,000 POLISHED LEATHER SADDLE
OVER HIS BACK, AND A PLUG
STUFFED INTO HIS BACKSIDE THAT
GAVE HIM A BEAUTIFUL ARCHING
TAIL.
HE REARED UP ONTO HIS HIND LEGS,
REVEALING THE HORSELIKE
MANHOOD ON HIS UNDERSIDE.
(GROANS)
YES, WEIRD AL.
>> THAT'S THE MITT ROMNEY I
KNOW.
>> Chris: YES!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THERE'S THE ROMNEY/PAUL SLASH
PIC.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
CARROT TOP OR ONE DIRECTION?
IS THIS CARROT TOP OR ONE
DIRECTION?
YOU CAN'T HELP BUT LAUGH
ALONG WITH HIM.
HE IS COVERED IN RED SPLOTCHES
AND YOU LOOK DOWN AT YOUR OWN
BODY TO FIND THAT YOU ARE AS
WELL.
YES, SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> THAT IS CARROT TOP, THE RED
SPLOTCHES.
>> Chris: NO, ONE DIRECTION.
>> WHAT?!
>> Chris: I DON'T KNOW.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
I'M SORRY, AL.
ARE YOU OKAY?
BRIAN, ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
>> I AM ALL RIGHT.
CHANGE THE GRAPHIC, I'M
ALL RIGHT.
>> Chris: WHAT IS WRONG WITH
FIVE YOUNG HANDSOME...
>> CHANGE THE GRAPHIC!
>> Chris: WHAT GRAPHIC ARE
YOU REFERRING TO?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> LOOK BEHIND YOU.
>> THE REMOTE IS AROUND HERE
SOMEWHERE TO GET RID OF THIS
WONDERFUL GRAPHIC.
>> IT'S SNEAKING UP ON YOU.
>> BURN IT WITH FIRE!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THERE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, HERE IS THE
NEXT ONE.
WEIRD AL OR CHRIS HARDWICK?
>> ONE OF THE GIRLS STARTED
CARESSING HIS CHEEK AND
HER AFFECTION WAS REWARDED BY
A NASTY SWAT AS IF A FLY HAD
LANDED ON HIS FACE.
"COOL IT, BABY.
AFTER THE SHOW,
IF YOU'RE LUCKY."
>> THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED TO ME,
SO I'M GOING TO SAY ME.
>> Chris: YES, THAT HAPPENED TO
WEIRD AL.
THERE IT IS, THAT FAN FICTION.
DOCUMENTARY.
(APPLAUSE)
"MY STALLONIA"?
COME ON, GUYS.
>> "STALLIONA," PLEASE.
>> Chris: I'M SORRY.
OH, THAT'S RIGHT, STALLONA
IS YOU RIDING STALLONE.
>> THAT WAS THE FOLLOWUP.